Speaker 1: We are now getting to the point
of being able to talk about easing mass guidelines,
Joe Biden, in fact, today is set to make a
statement about masking as a follow up to
what we're expecting to be an easing of outdoor
mass guidelines by the CDC.
I already said yesterday this makes absolutely
perfect sense based on the science.
Tucker Carlson on Fox News cannot simply leave
it at that.
Tucker has to go further and not only attack
masking, but demand that people bully mask
wearers if they see them wearing masks if
they want to.
Let's jump right into this segment from last
night.
First part of the segment
Speaker 4: we did give in this grotesque version
of Halloween went on for more than a year,
and it's still going on.
Not even Tony Foushee still pretends that
or medically necessary instead mass are purely
a sign of political obedience, like Kim Il
sung Penns in Pyongyang, we wear them because
we have to.
The only people who wear masks voluntarily
outside are zealots and neurotics.
How neurotic are they?
Well, we know a Pew survey from last March
found that 64 percent of white Americans who
classify themselves as liberal or very liberal
have been diagnosed with an actual mental
health condition.
And you see them everywhere when you walk
down the street in any major city.
Speaker 1: Now, the mental health thing is
very deceptive and ugly.
He doesn't mention what portion of all Americans
have been diagnosed and even diagnosed is
a complicated term because lots of people
have undiagnosed mental illness because they
refuse to go or don't have access to mental
health care.
And also simply being anxious counts as mental
illness.
In the poll that Tucker mentions, that's all
deceptive and very ugly and sort of used as
a cudgel.
But Tucker Carlson is right about one thing.
There is an aspect in which masks are theater.
I've been talking about it outdoors on bike
paths and sidewalks, especially after vaccination.
There is an element to masks being a theater.
It's a signal that you care.
Before anybody was vaccinated, one out of
a thousand cases were transmitted outdoors
and they were in obvious situations.
People crowded together in large groups outdoors.
No one is getting this walking by someone
on the sidewalk, even jogging by someone.
Check out the recent statements from Dr. Ashish
Jha from Brown University.
I never believed that that made sense, but
I did it to show I care.
So in a sense, there is an aspect of theater,
but we're getting beyond that now and it's
a good thing.
But somehow Tucker is attacking people's mental
health and then it gets much worse
Speaker 4: if you dare to go on foot from
Union Station to the Capitol, for example,
and watch without wearing a mask, angry Biden
voters will snort at you in judgment.
How could you they're saying from behind the
Gores, how could you?
That's the question we should be asking of
them in return.
The rest of us should be staring at them first.
They're the aggressors.
It's our job to brush them back and restore
the society we were born in.
So the next time you see someone in a mask
on the sidewalk or on the bike path, do not
hesitate.
Ask politely but firmly.
Would you please take off your mask now?
Speaker 1: This is really stupid.
I'm ready to stop wearing my mask outdoors.
Based on the coming CDC and Joe Biden's statements,
I expect governors to go with outdoor masking
is not needed but other people wearing them.
Why do I care if other people are wearing
masks?
If it's the middle of summer and I see somebody
wearing a winter hat?
I think that's odd.
It doesn't seem comfortable, but what difference
does it make to me if someone wants to wear
a wool winter hat in the middle of summer,
go ahead and do it as long as you don't make
me do it.
I think the judgment of people not wearing
masks outdoors as these guidelines is.
It's something that will have to be dealt
with, but tell other people to take off masks,
it doesn't really sound like liberty and freedom,
even that so-called conservatives advocate
for.
That's not making sense.
And then it just gets worse.
Speaker 4: Science shows there is no reason
for you to be wearing it.
Your mask is making me uncomfortable.
We should do that.
And we should keep doing it until wearing
a mask outside is roughly as socially accepted
as lighting a marble in an elevator.
It's repulsive.
Don't do it around other people.
That's the message we should send because
it's true.
Speaker 1: I don't know if Tucker believes
that, quite frankly, like I think he knows
his audience will love it.
But then to actually go into how to deal with
kids wearing masks, he says, call child services.
Speaker 4: As for forcing children to wear
masks outside, that should be illegal.
Your response when you see children wearing
masks as they play should be no different
from your response to seeing someone beat
a kid and Wal-Mart.
Call the police immediately, contact Child
Protective Services, keep calling until someone
arrives.
What you're looking at is abuse.
It's child abuse, and you are morally obligated
to attempt to prevent it.
If it's your own children being abused, then
act accordingly.
Let's say your kid's school emailed you to
announce that every day after lunch, your
sixth grader was going to get punched in the
face by a teacher.
How would you respond to that?
That's precisely how you should respond.
When they tell you that your kids have to
wear masks on the soccer field.
That is unacceptable.
It is dangerous.
And we should act like it because it is.
But too few of us have responded like that.
Speaker 1: So that is just completely off
the rails.
Tucker starts with the kernel of a good idea.
Science doesn't support the need for outdoor
masking.
Great crossover agreement.
I will join Tucker in a bipartisan way on
that issue.
Then he drops in.
64 percent of liberals are mentally ill.
Wait, hold on.
Where is this going?
Then he goes in to tell other people to take
off their masks because you don't like it.
Well, hold on.
Now, that's authoritarian and overbearing
and then called Child Protective Services.
If you see a kid wearing a mask.
Hello, police get CPS here.
There is a mask wearing on a playground.
What we need instead.
Ah, just clear new guidelines from the CDC
not to weaponize mask wearing against people
by involving child services or police.
That's not that far from like Alex Jones type
stuff about putting kids in camps or whatever.
It's like a soft Alex Jones with better writing,
lighting and makeup.
That's essentially what Tucker Carlson has
become.
And the colonel was was not crazy about outdoor
masking.
And the CDC is set to agree with the colonel
of that and then it just goes completely off
the rails.
My question is, do you think Tucker believes
this stuff or Tucker is doing it because he
knows his audience will absolutely love it?
I don't know.
Let me know what you think